[Music]
I love there's only one messenger Allah
Allah
there's only one welcome Jesus once his
messenger Allah may come greetings of
peace how you guys doing welcome to the
Deen show and every week we're here
subscribe if you haven't already to get
the newest show sent to you and with no
exception we have another exciting show
with our brother the golden child
Hamza how are you brother I'm doing
welcome good luck I don't make a Ramadan
bloody cancel out on robotic teeth so
you were the golden child I was in a
manner of speaking yeah so tell us I got
the head to prove it sir I can't you
came from predominantly
well that's interesting because in India
it's predominantly either Muslim or
Hindu right correct correct and then we
talked about the colonization time when
they came over and then the missionaries
came and your parents can you go off
from there yeah so my family is actually
they've been Christian for a few
generations I think at least three or
four and but I'm sure at some point
somebody was was Hindu and then you know
the colonists came and then they
converted a lot of people over to
Christianity so I'm a product of a few
generations of colonial Evangelical
Protestant Christian thought and
ideology that's kind of my background
and my parents background so how did you
end up here on the Deen show what was it
now about Islam that had you accepted
also holla it was a long road it was a
long road but in a nutshell it was the
Quran it was the overwhelming beauty of
the Quran from the moment that and and I
wasn't somebody that learned about Islam
and then just immediately went to the
Quran and started reading it it took me
a while for the Quran to come in
front of my face and when it finally did
and when I opened it I wasn't able to
put it down I had changed my life
forever now was this one of those things
that because you'll see some of these
stories you know the person had some
kind of dream right and that Jesus or
someone came to arm and that just
changed their life you know it was was
that something like that it's like
usually a unique experience just for
that person right not based on much
textual evidence correct yeah so my
journey the interesting thing about my
journey is that it wasn't a emotional
experience for me and I did my best to
kind of separate emotion from my
decision-making process so just a little
bit of background I mentioned my
family's Christian they're not only
Christian by the way they're wonderful
people but they're not only Christian
but you know they're very involved in
the Christian community a lot of my
uncle's are pastors and a lot of our
family friends are you know have their
own churches so I grew up in that
environment where Christianity was not
only very prevalent it was I grew up in
the church I grew up in the community
and as you alluded to earlier as the
golden child I was I'm the only child of
my parents but in terms of our family we
were highly respected within the
community so I was I was you know doing
well
I had no overwhelming reasons to leave
the beam but subhanAllah Allah guides
people in different ways and the way
that that I came to Islam was in stages
the first stage of my life was where I
was questioning Christianity and I know
this happens to a lot of people but the
more I would learn about Christianity I
had questions in the back of my head
questions that I asked my family like
what questions what kind of questions
things like you know um if if God had
told God had told all the prophets in
the Bible especially Moses peace be upon
him that you know your God
is one from the gecko and this was the
understanding for most of the children
of Israel and they practiced this for
you know thousands of years and that
didn't change until after Jesus peace be
upon him left this earth and then
somebody else came and and made a
statement on his behalf which changed
the paradigm from that moment onward so
from that point everybody worshiped one
God and and they knew that the one God
had sent prophets after that they said
no the Prophet that then Paul said the
Prophet that that that God had sent the
Jews Jesus peace be upon him he actually
wasn't just a prophet he was actually
God you know in in the form of a man and
that really that idea didn't resonate
properly with me I had questions about
that I said why is it that you know God
changed flip the script so to speak all
of a sudden you know why didn't he just
tell people from time of Adam all the
way down that hey you know what I'm God
but really there's a triune nature to me
you know and you should worship all
three that would have been a very simple
message now when people go back and they
go and they start digging into you know
some of the earlier books of the Bible
right the Old Testament they try to
connect that they try to make that
correct that try and I've seen that I've
seen that attempt and it's kind of a
sloppy attempt in my opinion and and the
interesting thing about it is that when
they go back and they and I don't
remember the verses off top of my head I
used to at one point but I don't now but
when they go back to like the books of
Isaiah and Deuteronomy and they try to
make the connections between Jesus and
who they think or their understanding of
God it they usually do one of two things
first thing is they fail miserably and
the second thing is they usually prove
the reality of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon them you know because when
they go back to like Deuteronomy 1818
when they go back to certain verses in
the Old Testament and even in the New
Testament you know they all allude to
the coming of a prophet
after Jesus that he himself spoke about
like in the book of Matthew he he spoke
about the coming of another prophet who
wouldn't speak from himself he would
just do whatever God commanded him to do
so and that's and and that fits the bill
for the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him exactly so a lot of that was
overwhelming evidence for me but going
back to what I was saying earlier is
that so when I had doubts about
Christianity and I and I went and I
spoke to some people at my church doubts
in Christianity for people that are
coming from that area of faith where
it's just taken on belief what we say is
absolute if your story doesn't fall in
line with the story that's accepted it's
usually rejected nobody really wanted to
hear my side of things from my thoughts
about things so what I started to do is
I went on a personal journey to just
read about religion so I lost faith in
religion and especially in Christianity
when when a lot of my family members
they would claim that Jesus had spoken
to them in one way shape or form via
vision or dream or whatever and they
were all on different pages they had
they all had different ideas about how
to do things they couldn't agree on
things now that necessarily in itself
isn't a bad thing but that kind of made
me that made me sour to to the faith
that you know what you have these people
who claim to be so close to God but at
the same time God's giving them all
different messages that's what it seemed
like to me and it was a it was one of
those things that made me decide that
you know what I need to look at look
into this for myself
you know up until this point I was just
listening and obeying but I wasn't
thinking so when I started thinking I
started reading books I actually went
away from Christianity and as I said I
didn't come to Islam until much later
but I went away from Christianity I
started going down the path of just
science because some of the things that
I heard in Christianity were very
outlandish that didn't make sense to me
rationally things like a story of
it was Joshua how he prayed to God to
stop the Sun and he just stopped the Sun
and I was like well if that happened you
know everything would have just
collapsed and at the time I just
couldn't wrap my head around those kind
of ideas so I went into science I
actually became atheist for a while
didn't believe in didn't believe in
anything just thought that there the
science was the way to go
science was you know absolute in the
sense that we either knew things or we
didn't know things there was no gray
area or at least as I understood so I
went from there and then I remember I
read this book I can't recall the name
of the person who made this quote but it
stuck with me and it helped me get back
into faith and that was a quote I think
it was Thomas Aquinas something to the
effect or it might have been somebody
else but something to the fact that when
you religion or faith is basically like
for example if you had a tornado that
that went through that swept through
junkyard and then perfectly assembled as
a working 747 jet you know that's what
faith basically is like you know you're
saying that the faith in science is
producing these these results but it's
not and so that kind of left a profound
impact with me I said you know what
you're right I mean the way that we are
now the way that our bodies universe how
everything is designed it must have a
designer it must have a creator things
couldn't just you know automatically
have come together and started working
on yeah we got a lot more to talk about
one ask you about your family how they
how they took it and now the title with
the golden child because obviously you
were really they were they were
preparing you to come up in the church
right correct yeah we're going to go
from there don't go anywhere for the
exciting episode with humza we right
back thank you my friends caring and
sharing so like and share this video and
support the Dean show so that we could
continue educating and sharing the
message of peace peace is acquired by
submission to the will of God Islam with
the world a Salaam alaikum peace be with
you
welcome back to the Dean show so what
was your your name before you accepted
Islam so my name before accepting Islam
was Sunil
it's a primarily Hindu name which caused
a lot of confusion for people because I
actually recently legally changed it to
Hamza Sunil doesn't mean anything it
just means I think it's the color of
blue yeah and and I think there was a
lot of famous cricket players in India
that were names - Neil yeah so my father
you know he named that he named me that
and so you know when I became Muslim I
wanted to have my Islamic identity I
watched the movie the message powerful
movie powerful Metheny quinn anthony
quaint that's a classic yes everybody
needs to watch that the message right
the messenger or the message I believe
the message the message yes is advancing
equipment wonderful movie I watched it
in high school
VHS VHS back in the two of them oh yeah
- oh he'll write part 1 part 2 it was
back in like 98 yeah before we had all
this technology but a wonderful movie I
saw the character of Hamza and I
immediately connected with that
character and it wasn't until and then I
became Muslim in 2002 it wasn't until
2002 and somebody said hey you know if
you want to choose a name for yourself
this would be a good time and and I went
through and I said you know this was
this is the name Hamza I love the name I
love the the meaning
I loved the message behind the name so
and and it fits little bit for me thumbs
up so we got Hamza here so now your
parents who was it that brought Islam to
you who brought you - who shared who
gave you Dow was anyone particular or
will you on your own pretty much or did
you have a classmate did you have
someone that you had conversations with
and they start to you know bring up
certain questions and had you thinking
correct yeah so I did have a lot of good
people around me from the time of high
school a lot of good brothers and
sisters that were part of the the Muslim
Student Association at that time so you
have some Muslim friends I had some
Muslim friends
but what really all brought us together
with sports yeah big fan of basketball
we all used to go play sports and then
afterwards you know they would go to
these Muslim club meetings and they
would do things like watch the message
and do other things so I had good
influences but like I said for me I'm
not somebody that bases decisions off of
influence yeah till this day I've never
smoked a cigarette nobody has ever
influenced me to do anything that I've
never wanted to do myself so and my
family had this concern they said who
converted you to Islam who force you to
take this and I said nobody did I did I
read I researched and I came to this
being because from my understanding this
was the most perfect answer to life's
questions to all of life's questions and
they were they they couldn't wrap their
mind around it they said no it had to be
somebody so although I did have good
influences in my life I had good people
who I could conversate with but the
reality was these individuals were you
know there were teenagers they were
young adults they they had their
shortcomings they did whatever they
needed to do so I never saw anyone and
said hey you know what this is a
inspirational figure but when somebody
brought to my attention they said hey
you're studying about Taoism and
Confucianism and Hinduism and the other
branches of Christianity why don't you
look at the Quran you know why don't you
look at some of the the meanings behind
the Quran and so in that way I was
approached about about Quran in the
Islam that's a very sensible thing to do
I mean there's a nice story of a Muslim
Christian and the Jew got together and
they started talking about religion and
the Jews says hey look we only I only
believe in Jesus and I mean Moses and
his Commandments and the Christian steps
up and says hey I believe in Moses but
also in Jesus on the elevated malva see
the God and then they look at the bosom
and the Muslim says hey I believe in we
believe in Moses Jesus and the last and
final mention problem how man
must be upon him so this is in no way
you know putting down Jesus and no way
putting down Moses in no way you know
coming and attacking or you know really
just inviting people to look at what
Jesus is real message was and look at
what he was talking about another
messenger because it's clear if you read
it like you were yeah that there was
another messenger who was coming
otherwise it's incomplete yeah it's it
in my opinion and I think in many
people's opinion in Islam actually
elevates Jesus because Christianity
brought him brought Jesus peace be upon
him at the same status of of I think it
was one of the pagan gods that they had
you know formed his backstory behind I
forget the nearest Mithras so a lot of
the things that present day Christians
do now is a result of Constantine and
Paul and some of the people back in the
day that had been made decisions that
have nothing to do with people today
they made the decision that hey you know
what the easiest way for us to take a
message that was meant only for the
Jewish people and and Jesus mentions
that specifically in the New Testament I
think when a woman comes up to him and
says you know I have such a such problem
can you help me and he said I wasn't
sent here for you I was sent here for
the children of Israel and and so they
had to kind of figure out how to marry
those two ideas that the fact that Jesus
came for the Jews but then also for the
Gentiles and and so then Paul and
Constantine and whoever they got
together and said hey you know what
we're going to we're going to marry
Mithras this this mythical Hajin
mythological figure that we have and
we're going to and this real person that
we have Jesus marry their identity so I
think Christianity brings Jesus down
whereas Islam elevates him his name he
is a prophet of Allah a beloved
messenger to the Muslims and I'm sure to
a lot of Christians as well but at the
same time when when you equate him next
to God that's that's putting him in a
tough position
you know I mean I mean nobody wants to
be the guy that's like oh hey you're on
the same status as God I mean he's going
to deny that on the day of judgment
which is what we firmly believe but
that's that's a difficult position to be
in
what are your parents now okay so what
was that there's a crossing point and
many people don't want to cross that
point right of no return because now
you're the golden child correct right
your family
their name is on the line right social
status maybe you got some big
inheritance coming your way you're going
to hurt the kingdom over here right from
from everything your parents have the
money these are the kind of things
people have to think about right and
Islam makes sense there's it just
worship the creator not the creation
everything is so crystal clear but now
the courage to step forward and to say
you know what I'm going to follow this
truth right right or you're going to
succumb to the temptation of look it's
this is more important right I'm not I'm
just going to kind of just keep blending
in and just people abandon the clothes
correct what was that that thing that
had you say you know what I'm not
holding back I'm going to give birth to
what's inside of me I'm going to come
out and I'm going to accept that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens and earth and
what Muhammad is allowed to final
mentioned that's what someone has to do
it become a Muslim and obviously that
would include Jesus Moses and all the
preceding messengers you wouldn't just
abandon them we would just give them the
proper do that they were mighty
messengers not divine with God
correct correct so that was the turning
point for me or the point of no return
to kind of understand that I have to
take just a step back and that step back
was that the way that I was raised you
know I me and my family went through
some difficult periods during my
childhood and it got to the point where
for me and my mom you know she told me
you're my only hope you know I'm hoping
that you grow up to be a good Christian
son of mine so that you can get me out
of all the challenges that I faced and
so a lot was riding on my shoulders from
the family perspective I also had my
uncles who were trying to pedigree me
towards being intricate part of the
church
not saying that I had to be the next
pastor or anything but definitely
involved deeply in the church so a lot
of people had a lot of Hope in me and
what what made me change my mind is that
if i if i had looked at this whole
experience through an emotional lens i
would have definitely never embraced the
song so one one day I was sitting with
one of my friends his name is Muhammad
by the way I'm interestingly enough and
he and I this is after I had gathered
all this information about other
religions as well as Islam and I knew in
my heart that Islam is at the absolute
perfect way of life it's what I want to
do so now you're at that planet how far
in to your journey is this is this a few
months few years how approximately how
long before you realize okay this is it
this is what I've been saying this is
the truth
so I started around 2000 yeah and it
took me about two years to get to okay
so this is not something just like
overnight no no you took your time I
really really critical thinking for us
prayer what you know were you asking God
for guidance in yourself or is
reflecting on on things that I knew yeah
things that I understood to be true
things that didn't make sense to me yeah
I was trying to just put all those
things together and kind of thread the
needle to what was real and what was
obviously not real so now you're here
okay so you're about two years into
investigating you know really doing some
critical thinking and contemplating and
so what happens from there yeah and not
just contemplating but actual research
research research I locked myself up in
my parents then and just was reading
books and you know I would do research
on religion I was at you're digging man
I'm digging okay so I I went to UIC for
the first couple years of my college
2000-2002 that's by the way where I took
my Shahada but while I was there I was
researching so much on the Dean that you
know setting it up not dropping out of
UIC because this was so overwhelmingly
profound for me but so fast-forward 2002
I'm
talking with my friend Muhammad as I
mentioned and he said one thing to me
which I'll always remember
don't don't don't lose your place yama
tells you something this is this is
obviously a friend this is a friend of
yours from the you I see correct we'll
be right back with more here on the D
show don't go anywhere
so you have two choices either be a
slave to the creation or be a slave to
the creator and submit yourself to him
like all of there's no prophets and
messengers did hope this got you
thinking take the first step and start
asking sincerely for guidance from your
Creator thank you don't forget to share
and like this video subscribe and do
your best to help the Deen show reach
its goal thank you very much Salaam
alaikum peace be with you
welcome back to the Dean show Hamza in
the studio golden child family comes
from a staunch Christian background they
were how they were preparing you to be
what like a pastor in the church er yeah
I was being pedigree to be some type of
figure in the church yeah
but definitely from a very conservative
Christian background yeah okay so where
you left off now that Mohammed your
friend Mohammed what happened from there
so I was just having a talk with him I
think we were just we had just gotten
some food or whatever just having like a
casual conversation so he says something
to me that I'll always remember for the
rest of my life and he said now that you
have all of this information that you've
amassed really from like 1998 because
when I started really thinking about
religion but 2000s when I researched
religion and he said now that you have
all this information what are you going
to do with it because if you die in a
state where you have all this
information but you didn't act on it
then God could hold you accountable for
not making that decision so that was a
very moving statement for me because
that meant I had to take some action it
wasn't just lip service anymore I
couldn't just pretend that I'm still
researching I knew where I needed to go
I just had to have the courage to go
there and so shortly after March 29th of
2002 I went to UIC and after their
Friday prayer I went up and you know I
had already arranged it with some of
their people there and I took my Shahada
got a lot of hugs it was a very
emotional moment at that point but
getting to that point I tried to use as
much logic and reasons let's help people
identify how to like paint the picture
you get up to what this is when someone
finally acknowledges after research
contemplation asking God for guidance
and now this is the truth this is
nothing new this is what every messenger
brought what is this jihad that what did
you say actually so the Shahada is what
is the declaration of faith it's a
shadow under Allah
ahoo ahoo luxury condo I shadow under
muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluh so that
you're basically saying and it's a very
profound thing and I'm and I moved just
hearing it now yeah it's a very profound
thing because you're basically saying
that there's nothing no one worthy of
worship but Allah but you're not just
saying that you're casting aside
anything that could even be tried to
compare to Allah and you're putting
Allah above everything and then you're
saying that from from the mercy of Allah
he sent the final messenger the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him to clarify
all these misconceptions that were made
about Allah and so that's why Muhammad
is beloved to me and to all the Muslims
because he came to really set the record
straight about who God is and what God
wants and how God wants us to approach
him so for me it's a very profound
statement when I met it when I made that
statement I was nearly in tears and I
wasn't serious Allah there is a verse in
the Bible I believe it's in John 17:3
I'm not mistaking where it says this is
life eternal that they may know you
where this is alleged Jesus speaking
says this is life eternal that they may
know you now he's pointing you not me is
that you the only true God and Jesus
whom you have sent
correct Shahada that's a hell that's it
this is this is that testimony that
you're acknowledging that look the only
one worthy of worship is not a man not a
woman not a saint not a messenger not an
angel not money not fame nothing but the
creator of the heavens on earth the one
who gave you life will give you death
and the messenger that was sent at that
time during Jesus's time it was him he
was the messenger Moses at the time you
would say the same statement and then
acknowledge that Moses of the teacher
the messenger teaching you how to
worship how to get to paradise right
correct and Abraham it was the same
statement in his time and then now we
have it our time problem Hamid peace and
must be upon the last and final
messenger the seal of the prophets and
you were doing nothing different same
thing I was doing the exact same things
and it was an honor to do it a person
all their sins everything from the past
day it's a fresh start fresh start ups
but did hell all hell break
after that yeah how does n't like it
done real now it's real now yeah yeah
and I you're tested the ones that God
Almighty loves the most he touched the
most correct right so then all hell
break loose in a manner of speaking yes
now my parents were wonderful people I
love them to death you know they had a
very hard time with this I didn't I
didn't initially approached him about it
because I kind of had a feeling how they
would take it I kind of hid my Islam at
home I would when I flirt when I took my
Shahada people friends from high school
friends from college gave me gifts books
to put on copies of the hadith and I had
put all these in a nice little cabinet
in my in my den where I was doing all my
research and so I hid my thumb and I
came home one day and I looked inside
this cabinet and all those things were
gone and I started just freaking out and
I was like ah where's all this stuff so
I looked everywhere and then I finally
went to my mom and I said you know mom
have you seen these things that I've
placed you know around this desk and she
she she knew what I was talking about
and she said what things are you talking
about and I said you know there were
some books and some other things she was
like yeah I found some things and I
threw them in the garbage and my heart
literally dropped to my stomach and I
felt like the blood loss from my brain
it was a surreal moment for me and I was
just like oh man I mean she had just
thrown the Quran away something that
brought me to the Dean and I went
through a a different set of emotions
but what I did was I left the house and
I went to the Mudgett anytime I had any
issues I would go to the Masjid and
that's that's a practice that I
encourage and I'd do till this day I
went to the Mudgett and one of the old
Mudgett caretakers there or he was
really the only one a wonderful man
wonderful man his name is some he's a
person that I will remember you know for
the rest of my life we used to call him
the movies
it's something in order but his name is
muhammad hafiz again he came to me he
said why are you looking so sad today
what's wrong and I said I don't even
know how to explain this to you but my
mom just threw away everything that I
that I owned about Islam especially the
Quran and and I was in tears and so he
looks at me and he kind of chuckles he
was like he smiles and I'm thinking in
my head like why is he smiling this is a
very serious moment like I'm I've just
lost a lot of things that I really am
care about and I'm passionate about and
then and then he says something to me
which I'll never forget he says your
mother may have thrown out the Quran
which is a book which she could never
throw out the Quran which is in your
heart she can never extinguish that that
light and that really it literally
sprung me back into action it was the I
felt like I had been knocked out and
then this before the 10-count I was back
up cinema I was back up and I was ready
to go that charged me and it's still
charging me for the entirety of my life
so it's individuals like that that you
know they have a profound impact on new
reverted Muslims and they may not know
it at that time you know and I always
pray for that brother and his family but
that really charged me to get back into
things and to also give my parents the
benefit of the doubt you know it can't
be easy to lose your son to another
faith something you know I have kids now
myself if my child came to me and said
you know I want to practice something
else it would deeply hurt me too so it
made me understand my parents
perspective I didn't intend to you know
hurt them when I made this choice I just
knew that this was the right thing for
me to do and I deeply and sincerely
wished it you know they had considered
it then and they even consider it now so
for me it's been a personal journey to
really educate them about Islam we went
back and forth that at one point they
said you know we don't want to hear
about Islam anymore and so now I make
duaa and I try to be the best son that I
can be hopefully those actions because I
know that this is the Sunnah of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu name this
is his way that you not only talk about
the good but you do the good in the
hopes that people will see that good and
and worship Allah
now they had did they have a bunch of
people like them because you had a large
family of people who are prominent in
the church people lined up to try to
like you know maybe I think maybe he's
possessed you know that works of
exorcism on you they try to like common
usually what you'll see happening is
people will try to distort Islam to try
to take them the matters of thick and
things I do some ambiguity as far as
need some clarification where people can
get confused and they'll start to attack
I know did this happen there was a lot
of people from LaVon BAM Gong attack
right they were on the strong offensive
they were from my family like I
mentioned my uncle's are pastors some of
our family friends are all pastors very
deep within the church they all came you
know lined up outside my door in a
manner of speaking they would be intent
of bringing me back to Christianity you
know they told me things like you know
God is a spirit it's it's they were
trying to explain my question of why did
God change the paradigm after Jesus and
before Jesus it was all the same and
they were trying to explain to me you
know that God is a spirit and you know
he didn't really communicate the
completeness about himself but now after
Jesus we know the completeness and they
made a lot of attempts and you know all
those attempts now I didn't really know
much about the foundations of Islam I
mean I knew enough of the Quran and I
knew enough about Christianity to say
Christianity is not for me
Islam is definitely for me I need to
learn more but when people come to you
and they accuse the Prophet Mohammed or
ISM of XY and Z things that they
consider to be crimes you know I didn't
really have any adequate
sponsor them mm-hmm so I had to just
listen to all of this barrage of kind of
insults to the religion while being
patient at the same time and and then
then going back and then I had to hit
the books hard and learn what what are
they really talking about is there any
truth to what they're saying and you
know you always have as a new Muslim you
always have that fear in your mind that
maybe if I turn this page you know
there's something that I'm going to
learn that's going to take me back but I
had the confidence in Islam everything
that I had learned I knew I was sound
upon I knew that there was only one God
you know that anyone else claiming to be
God which Jesus peace be upon him never
did and but anyone claiming to be God
that couldn't be the right way anyone
speaking to God directly you know that
he had he himself had not chosen I took
them with a grain of salt
like someone just saying look like many
many people they'll do they'll say look
God spoke to me I'm speaking of God
today they're living they're saying that
that's ridiculous it's it's intense
because they come to you they have a lot
of passion a lot of fervor and they
sincerely believe that God or somebody
speaking to them in one way shape or
form visions dreams and for the most
part the thing that I love about the
religion of Islam the most is that we
base our our belief on on facts and
evidence facts and evidence that's very
important that's very important too
because and so the way that I look at it
and my approach is this is that we know
that God has sent messengers in the past
and we know that this is the practice of
God he sends messengers to people those
messengers try to deliver the truth but
invariably they get you know for manners
in a manner of speaking they get
crucified in one way shape or form but
the interesting thing to me was that
Islam was saying that this didn't happen
to Jesus that God saved him that God
elevated him and that he will come back
and then when he comes back people are
going to come back to him and say you
know we did all these wonderful things
in your name
and he's going to brush them aside so
for me that was an interesting thing to
learn about Islam that the way that
Islam saw Jesus peace be upon him the
way that Islam saw prophets in general
that there were all messengers you know
from God and the final messenger being
Muhammad's awesome that he came not just
for a specific nation but for all of
mankind and that was profound because it
made me realize then that you know it's
not a racist thing or a cultural thing
or you know there's no class or anything
associated with it it's it's for
everyone yeah here's many ridiculous
statements being made and I'm sure
you're probably hit with them there
they're just so ridiculous and if
someone does this I often bring my book
I said look you got to read the Complete
Idiot's Guide I never met this brother
but I'm sure he's he's gonna we should
meet one day I keep I keep pushing his
book if you got to be a complete I love
the Complete Idiot's Guide to
understanding Islam because you got to
be a really complete I never want to you
know name call anybody but just
generally speaking you really got to
come be a complete idiot if you believe
some of these things and just swallow it
whole for instance that Muslims worship
the moon right right that allows a moon
God when you just I mean Allah says
don't worship the moon real simple
things of female female genital
mutilation ridiculous honor killings I
mean this is uh these are things you
know there's no honor in killing
innocent people basic things that you
look into you know the basic teachings
of Islam refute this with a little bit
of knowledge at and and then another
thing you know you see like did they try
to tell you that the Quran was from the
devil you know yeah a lot it's crazy
you know every book every page of this
book has God's name on it be interesting
if the devil wrote this and he's cursing
himself because the Quran is constantly
cursing the devil constantly telling you
to be truthful the devil trying to get
you to not be truthful to commit all
sorts of evil but everything in the
Quran what is it calling you to to do
good things to be a good human being
yeah did you hear some of these things
these attacks that started to come at
you absolutely I heard all those
and even more the one that was very
interesting for me that that there's
idols that so what people have done is
they've taken some information about the
history of Islam and then they've kind
of melded that in with their own
inclinations towards saying that Islam
and and Satanism is related in one way
shape or form so they've come to me and
they said you know there were idols in
the Kaaba before and you know that's
what that was Muhammad peace be upon him
is intent he wanted people to worship
the idols and things like this and that
couldn't be further from the truth we
all know as Muslims that when Mecca was
liberated first thing not a single
person was harmed not a single plant or
animal was touched or harmed and then
what the first thing that was that
occurred was all of the idols that were
placed by Arab pagans prior to Islam
those all those idols were removed from
the Kaaba and the Kaaba is just a
metaphorical place this is the place
where we believe that Adam peace be upon
him and then subsequently it Abraham
peace be upon him and his son built this
house as a worship to the Creator so
this is this is the symbolic and the
actual first house of worship for for as
Muslims understand it so it has a lot of
significance and this is why and it's a
unifying place of direction for everyone
instead of people playing praying to the
left or the right or whichever way they
seemed fit we're all unified in one
direction and we pray to the creator of
the universe so I've heard a lot of
things but they didn't hold a lot away
they did they were they really don't and
I I believe there's great wisdom in this
that anytime something is a value you
got to really put some effort into it
you know most of the precious things are
in the ground there's dirt covering it
right there's Lomb is a treasure so
there's a lot of dirt around around any
Allah is the creator god almighty is
just testing people's sincerity so are
you going to some people it's are you
going to go back to the club are you
going to go back to that way of life
that you were living before right of
following your desires
because now you're tested here right
someone comes at you and now you like
yourself you go investigate you know
these things don't hold weight because
you obviously know the basic teachings
of Islam but some people right they fail
miserably on such a very basic test very
simple that if you were to just research
a little bit pray to God everything
would have been cleared out after the
desire strong many people now they get
tests and they go back to the club they
go back to the lifestyle that whatever
it doesn't necessarily be the club but
they go back to whatever they were doing
following their desires absolutely do
you see that that is and that all ties
in with emotions because desires
emotions all these things are related
and I'm just to make a comment on what
you said earlier about people who
practice these things in the name of
Islam like female general mutilation and
so many other killing knot and killing a
lot of these things are cultural
practices that have thrown dirt on Islam
that really have nothing to do they have
nothing to do with the religion of Islam
it's just people have brought their
cultures and ideas and try to you know
insert them in wherever they see fit one
of the things for me for example was you
know growing up as an Indian one of the
basic things is you know you don't get
married until you have your degree and
do all these things and and then
sometimes people go until the age of 30
before they can even find a spouse and
you know and and I see that as a
cultural norm that's perpetuated on
people that really causes people to go
to those extremes of clubbing or doing
this or that and committing sins but
culture can be a very beautiful thing it
can you know be an amazing thing but at
the same time it can be a very
destructive thing when it's implemented
in the wrong way and I've seen that
firsthand
yeah so what was it now have your
parents how they come around it's been
it's been how many years now since okay
2002 it's been some time now correct
right
so you got your feet come to love firmly
planted and Dean how was your
relationship now because Islam calls you
still to be the best son right towards
your parents to really honor and respect
your parents
right like your mother was saying that
she wanted some help and certain and she
was expressing herself
aslam doesn't take that away actually
takes her to a whole nother level have
they gotten to see that and has their
heart softened at all you know if I had
stayed a Christian and I know it's not
good to deal in hypotheticals but if
that were the case I don't know if I
would have been a good of son as I am
now that I'm Muslim not that I'm the
best that I have my flaws and I have my
mistakes but one of the things that
Islam compels people to do is to be good
to their parents and in in every manner
except if your parents ask you to
associate any partners to Allah to the
creator of the heavens in the air so
aside from that you know I've been as I
mentioned not trying to talk so much
about Islam but to show them Islam to
show them the good of his fun you know
really anything that they ask that I'd
be there for them
because you know I cherish and love them
for everything that they have done you
know the amount of love and respect that
one has for their parents this is
explained thoroughly in Islam thoroughly
in the Quran we're not even supposed to
say speak loudly towards our parents in
Islam as mentioned in the Quran so you
can imagine that it this is the level of
respect we have to show and I feel like
since I've become Muslim I've been able
to show them more respect more care and
you know and they're human beings and
they're a product of their parents
raising them a certain way in
Christianity so I recognize all of that
and I try to approach them you know with
the most care that I can possibly have
how's uh Ramadan now this is uh you've
been implementing another part again
Jesus he called people to worship the
Creator not the creation not himself
there's no where anywhere this is all
due respect with all due respect and
sincerity that this is not to put down
you know any religion anybody but we
when you critically think and you look
at the evidence it's clear that Jesus
called people you know just look at the
Lord's Prayer correct
or father we say our Lord who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name and if you
just did that you called on the one
Jesus called and asked for guidance God
will facilitate away and guide you to
submission to the will of God Islam so
you're not doing anything different
you took the Shahada that's what Jesus
would call what he called people to do
to testify there's nothing worthy of
worship except the Creator Jesus fell on
his face and prayed to God you're doing
the same thing that's right and Jesus
right he called people to give charity
that's the zakat again sounds
interesting huh that's what we're doing
the same way of life is all the
messengers nothing different and he
fasted Ramadan he did he says the same
thing so you're fasting now how's the
house remodel going Ramadan has been
going very well I'm the law in in what I
first became Muslim Ramadan was a bit of
a challenge and not from the fasting
perspective but from the perspective
that Ramadan is usually a time for
families to get together for people to
mend relationships and to really get
together and you know celebrate that the
Quran was given during the month of
Ramadan but then also to recognize that
there are less fortunate people in the
community and to also give back to the
community but overall to to increase us
in faith which is the main message of
Ramadan and when I was first Muslim I
would you know it's different when
you're the only one in your family doing
something and everybody else is doing
something else and then when you see you
know I would go to my friends houses for
Ramadan for any they would invite me
over to break fast with them and their
families and although I was very
grateful and appreciative of the
opportunity to break fast it inside I
was a bit sad because I couldn't do this
with my own family and one of the things
that I frequently prayed for is that for
one day for me to have my own family
that I could celebrate the joy and
happiness of Ramadan with and that
eventually one day and sha Allah even my
parents would be so bringing on without
with us as Muslims comes I mean and I
make that dwell all the time so that was
something that I wished for the longest
time in Salah now I have a wife and
three children and family
and Ramadan is a wonderful time for us
and and and I reflect back on those days
when I was by myself you know eating
cereal at home and then I think and I
say subhanAllah if somebody had told me
back then that you know what be patient
one day not only will you have your own
family but you will be amazingly happy I
would have said that that that could be
possible because I couldn't see that
happening I didn't know how I was going
to get out of my tough situation but
hamdullah Allah has a plan for everyone
and you know I'm grateful for Ramadan
I'm grateful for the ability to fast and
the great thing is now at the end of the
month we all get together even with my
parents so it's a wonderful time for me
guys it's very important I mean we take
some benefit much benefit from this
people who are really in a situation
where they don't have to struggle like
you did you follow me with their family
and having all hell break loose like
this you found me they are brought up in
a Muslim family you know breaking iftar
having a start together but many people
they're taking it for granted correct
you follow me correct
and I'm sure that touches your heart
also when you see the struggle that you
had to go through what advice do you
have for Muslims who are taking the Dean
for granted ah please don't that's the
first and foremost advice I mean it's
easier said than done the Dean has to
come from your heart it has to come from
after understanding the Dean and and
really wanting to change your life and
Allah says no Quran if somebody's
sincere about the Deen that Allah will
guide them to the Dean so just getting
rid of all the superficial things you
know getting rid of the cultural biases
you know if you have if you know of
people who are newly reverted Muslims or
people anyone who's who I was going
through some tough times you know invite
them to your house to eat you know give
them a smile this is one of the Sooners
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him one of the things that he used to
love to do and he encouraged us to do
which can really brighten someones
so that's my advice is you know don't
take Ramadan for granted don't take
being Islam for granted one of the
prayers I always make for myself and I
and I also pray for my family is that we
we take this understanding of Islam with
us all the way up until the moment we
die that this is something that we don't
ever take for granted not even for a
second yes that's deep in for everybody
watching in many of the not yet Muslims
people are tuning in and the message
makes sense worship to create a not to
creation there's some homework I want to
leave you with there is a qudsi hadith
we're proud muhammad peace be upon him
is relating to us that the Creator Allah
is saying that all of my slaves
are misguided every one of us is
misguided unless I guide them right
unless God guide you you're lost you
misguided so ask me God is saying ask me
of my guidance that is something so
simple is profound and there's
brilliance and simplicity something you
could do right now you can be that
person watching and maybe your family's
of the KKK right and you're like man I'm
not with that this makes sense I want to
be ELISA I want to be like Jesus was one
who submits to the will of God you could
do it right now you call 1 800 662 Islam
you could be as someone who was coming
from the strip club you can be someone
who is from the worst of background done
the worst of things there's always mercy
there's always forgiveness because God
is the all-merciful at all forgiving you
just got to have a sincere heart as God
asked the creator for guidance ask him
for forgiveness and if you have any more
questions call is
j+ ramadan take care thank you guys for
tuning in and subscribe if you haven't
already in tune in every week these are
the things that we talk about these
inspirational stories really touch the
heart so if you are tuning in for the
first time like I said do the homework
that I told you to do and call us if you
have any questions and we hope to see
you every week here on the Deen show
until next time peace be with you
something let us follow in the footsteps
of the greatest men who ever walked this
earth the messenger that God Almighty
sent like Abraham Moses Jesus and
Mohammed peace be upon them all who all
call people to worship the Creator alone
and not this creation take a moment now
fulfill one of those qualities and that
of giving towards the dollar-something
all these great giants did and call
people to do help us reach our yearly
goal from it out help you part of
sharing the truth support the detail
[Music]
you